you don't have to decide right away and
call the reference dozen so first I'll
see I'll be good she can watch codeine
and I'll have a good time you deserve
this early so at least encode here at
there Mommy and Me self-defense group
there will be your further half hour
how's your day busy sure you want me to
pour you a drink
she's pretty don't you think last leg
that was a huge mistake it can't happen
again
hey let me go this would be really sorry
Brian I'll be really sorry mr. and mrs.
Simon we have a few questions for you
what's this all about this was taken by
the security camera down the block I've
got two murders
any chance you recognize the figure in
that picture there are times that I've
broken up in the middle of the night and
she's not even in her room
makes me wonder if we've really been in
her emerge in have him she did they died
in a car crash when she was 12
everything that she told us from her her
background to her college
it was all online but now you know but
why it was because nothing was more
important to me than preserving our
family
you